what is going on guys this is
statistically challenged and welcome
back to another video today I've got an
awesome 1-hour challenge video on deck
we are gonna be doing one hour of the
gnome stronghold minigame now if you
don't know what this is this is
basically just it's called the gnome
restaurant and I'm going to show you my
inventory setup as you can see in the
description the first link I've left is
the link to the wiki page for this
minigame
it talks about all the requirements and
all the recipes for all the food you
have to prepare for people who are going
to bring to the NPC's around runescape
if I had to make a requirement guide and
show you guys how to do it this video
would be so lengthy so this is just for
the challenge guys if you want to learn
how to do this yourself please refer to
the wiki page it would tell you it way
better than I could now to start this
mini game all you have to do is come
over here to the gnome stronghold it's
the first floor and you're just going to
run east into the mini game icon as you
can see we have the Dreaming staff full
graceful 30k starting cache 25 house
tabs and a few super energy potions now
before you can actually take part in the
mini game there are a few requirements
you have to do all of its written at the
beginning of the wiki guys so do that
and then you can start doing the quest
you're gonna basically be using the wiki
for the entire process ok guys we do now
have the stopwatch open you're gonna see
how much money we can make from the
gnome restaurant minigame in exactly one
hour I'm going to start the timer right
now and to talk to Jionni jr. to get my
first offer let's see what we have to do
I missed the message on that I'm gonna
check the box so we needed to go to norm
norm a diem fluff room the current
orders some warm crunchies so we're
gonna make that and go to him and then
we have cut to the video and see what we
get as the tip oh yeah guys just
remember that all the ingredients you
need for all the crunchies and battles
are all in this store right here so you
don't have to go anywhere all you have
to do is pretty much just come right to
this store and you can use the note
cooker break here and make every dish
just in the restaurant remember that all
the recipes are on the wiki page I
didn't say this in the live commentary
because I forgot but yeah all the
recipes are on the wiki page it makes
your life 180 thousand times easier
alright guys were just gonna talk to him
give him the worm crunchies
we're gonna get a tip all right we got
three uncut opals kind of a lucky let's
go right back and get our another order
by the way if you're wondering how I got
here so fast there is literally a fairy
ring right here so yeah make sure you do
get that Lost City done and dream staff
it's really helpful dark or wants a
cheese and tomato vada easy peasy
getting right on that usually this NPC
is actually located near the king on a
patrol monkey madness - it's actually
just right here you put tips us again
pretty unlucky we got the uncut red
topaz these gems are the lowest tips
that you can actually get we're gonna
keep at it guys hopefully we can find
the gnome scarf or these seed pods in
this hour I'll just be absolutely amazed
all right guys
there's the man wink stone got him -
Chuck and Saturday we did this one
pretty fast because all we had to do was
use a berry ring again oh my god oh my
god we just got the 5 grand seed pod
drop boys holy [__] give that a price
check we just made a mil dude it's that
easy by the way I'm using my boy drew
Gees house it's a [__] epic that's
the only reason I got the grand seed pod
man cuz of his house but yeah let's get
back and get another order dude I can't
believe we actually hit it he has spies
or you got another super easy one
ambassador Kimball WAP I think we
already did this but he must be a
vegetable ball all right we are here
what are we gonna get for the tip three
toadflax not that bad I've gotten this
before when I was testing this out yeah
at 6 7 K not terrible alright next up is
my man Captain data King what's a drunk
dragon five uncut emeralds not too bad
man that took like three minutes not too
bad how much is that worth four point
five K you know it was an easy order so
I'll let it slide alright guys so for
the next order we got to go to
ambassadors spend tipple I think Rd did
this guy once this is the guy on I know
he's in the white knights castle we got
this thing called they were war token
I'm just gonna activate it I have no
idea what it does do whatever let's just
go make the when you seem to make some
spicy crunchies okay so when you
activate that you get some food
from the mountain terror chick he just
gave me a fruit betta I didn't even need
that but all right I guess we'll we'll
add that to the loot we'll add all the
tokens to the loot so that's part of it
alright guys we're here please give me
an ohm scarf or something good
another uncut a red topaz unlucky
alright guys next order is captain and
so we need blueberry special bro I'm a
[__] expert at making blueberry
specials I like three videos of me just
doing that sales go alright guys that
was easiest [__] alright that was
pretty easy
literally just first floor of our palace
what do we get for the tip Oh more uncut
emeralds not too bad those actually
stack so it's quite nice okay guys
captain Clem foodle is the next one
fruit blast
we're also hitting the 30 minute mark we
just did and it's going really well so
far guys I'm really enjoying this method
so yeah guys if you have the gliders
unlocked you'll have a much easier time
doing as you guys can see we literally
did this order in like 30 seconds 28
mithril bolts 28 mithril bolts what a
cheap-ass mafia then you can just glide
right back to the tree and you were
pretty much ready to go again because we
were right here all right guys we got
another token we're just gonna activate
it immediately and get a new task short
green guy for noir medium have a lot for
him so we just got delivered a pineapple
punch adding that straight to the loot
alright guys so this one is in the magic
field so all I'm going to do is go to
the nightmare zone teleport and I'm just
gonna use it that way I can just get to
gain Hill as fast as possible and it'll
save us the most time there is right
there and please give me something
absolutely sick more uncut emeralds god
damnit running low on house tabs you
might actually have to pull like a
couple more at the bank here okay we
literally just got the exact same person
but this time it's a different drink so
easy guys
yeah I also just pulled 20 more house
tabs out of the bank that way we cannot
run out so yeah this time instead of
using the Amazon teleport I just came to
Castle Wars and I'm just gonna run it
alright and what are we gonna get
another uncut red topaz yeah I don't
really expect to get anything like rare
super arrogant because I mean that's
literally all I wanted alright guys
Captain Durkin pretty easy
same drink though I'm just gonna drop an
energy pot and equip them in throw bolts
because I indeed need some more space in
my inventory and I want to keep all the
loot I acquired in my inventory as well
bro if this guy doesn't give me an ohm
scarf I quit Auto flocks whatever I'll
take it and we got another token we're
gonna activate that immediately
next order ambassador Spencer but we to
the sky like five times men okay with
the full inventory like that's actually
becoming pretty challenging to like
conserve all the spaces I have to start
dropping stuff I couldn't claim the
reward because my inventory was too full
so I'm gonna do it again all right we
got a fruit blast from the deliverer
alright guys so that one took much
longer than a two I just got so lost
yeah we got an uncut diamond not bad all
right guys what will be potentially the
second last order of the video can we
get something good
oh we got the uncut opals damn alright
one more order alright guys we've got
the fourth token of the video we're just
gonna activate it right away and get the
last order and we have ambassador gimbal
whap again this is gonna be a very easy
one alright guys we actually made it on
time the final order of the video what
do we get
oh [__] we actually got a bird's nest
for the final one we're gonna pop it up
when we got an acorn from that but yeah
guys we're gonna go to the grand
exchange now and try to sell off
everything to see how much we made there
we go that's the our stopped it on time
this time just to use the bird's nest
I'm gonna use a pestle mortar on it to
get a crush nest that way it can
actually sell to the grant exchange now
I'm gonna sell everything but the grand
seed pod to see how much we would have
made without that drop
[Music]
alright guys so keep in mind we started
with only 30k cash so you're gonna
deposit that I've deposited the 30k cash
and now we have 56 point 6 K without any
unique drops
although when you're doing this money
making method you were almost guaranteed
a gnome scarf or if the 5 grand seedpod
drops so now we're you're gonna sell
that so they weren't selling for full
price I probably could have made more if
I just leaving them in there but I
wanted to sell them really quick and we
got 797 K just for those so at the end
of the hour we totalled to about an 854
K profit we did use quite a lot of house
tabs and we used three super energies so
I'm just gonna take away 20k from that
so I'd say in real crop that we made 834
K as we normally do guys what we're
gonna do is give away all the profits to
a free-to-play noob this guy's stats are
free to play and he is a complete noob
look at that willow longbow and iron
helmet beep here we go we're gonna make
a stable and there you go hopefully you
can upgrade that with a longbow to a
maple longbow or something man then you
know what fan I'll take that as a bank
now if you guys made it to this point of
the video you are a absolute baller
please be sure to check out my other
content I had a lot of fun making this
video actually this minigames pretty fun
and it can be really profitable I know I
only did it for an hour but you should
expect around at least 800 K plus an
hour until next time guys have a good
day please leave a sub in a comment and
a like or dislike thank you guys for
watching and one quick thing before I
end the video guys I didn't put this in
the live commentary please be sure to
use the wiki page on the gnome
restaurant minigame and as it has
everything in great detail how to make
all the dishes where to go to all the
NPC's
what quests you need to reach all the
NPC's and it shows you the entire drop
table I think I included it at the
beginning of the video but please
reference the wiki page is gonna be in
the description and yeah that is fall I
have to say I'm gonna say it again boys
have a good day and thank you for
watching this video by the way I am
getting a pop filter relatively soon so
all the peas in this
won't be as your cancer as they come up
to be yeah